key face really does seem to affect
Elise in a much more personal way than
even a more powerful demon like redface
when dealing with redface she certainly
seems intimidated and concerned but with
keyface it's personal in one deleted
scene the demon locks her in this room
in her house and she starts crying and
feels helpless turning her into the
little girl once locked in the basement
by her father that's why I introduced
keyface the way I did at the beginning
of this video even if he doesn't possess
the raw power of red face or the diverse
subset of abilities as the man who can't
breathe it is Key's psychological
aspects that allowed him to haunt and
disturb the usually stoic hero more than
any other